what's up jonathan how are we doing so i
have two kids a
12 year old boy and a 10 year old girl
and
the 12 year old boy is i adopted him
i actually got with his mother when she
was a couple months pregnant actually
and i've been there ever since i was
there for the birth i was there
right for it all and um
she recently passed away a couple years
ago
and uh i'm sorry man my life has my life
has moved on now and
i've met a great woman and
we actually come up pregnant a month so
ago
or a couple months ago and um wasn't
planned but you know how that goes
um
yeah i know how that goes i know that
all works
yeah but um i'm going to tell you
congratulations anyway
congratulations brother well thank you
john i'm i'm excited now for a little
shocking but
i can't even wrap my head around what
that conversation would be like in my
house and my wife was like well
i got to tell you something when you get
home yeah so man congratulations brother
thank you um well it's going to be a boy
okay um and my wife's point is just
gonna be my first biological boy
and she don't want to
my son don't know that he's adopted yeah
and i heard the phone call the morning
of the the guy that found out he was
adopted and how it
affected him and i didn't know if i ever
planned on telling him in the
first place you know i i don't know i
just feel like i'm his dad you know it's
been there
um but my wife my wife thinks that
i shouldn't hide that from him and i
shouldn't hide it from
the new sign i just don't know how to go
about that doctor don't
know how to he he's 12 i'm not a i've
already had to tell him that his mom
won't come off from the hospital
and now i gotta tell him that you know
that i'm not his biological dad i just
don't know how to go about it
yeah so um number one man i appreciate
you
your heart on this deal yeah you said it
right you're in a predicament
um yeah
first and foremost no secrets man no
secrets
ever um no secrets no secrets no secrets
they destroy families they're a fire
that burns a family
to a crisp from the inside out it just
turns the whole thing to ash
the second thing is you're right on
man get rid of this biological language
you're about to have your second son
that is what it is with the purity into
that sentence
the moment you start saying well you're
that son
but this is my dude when you do that
you are creating chaos that you can
never you're creating trauma brother
that will burn through generations of
your family
and that's not your heart i know that
don't do that and
um you have to be pretty direct
with your new wife that there is not
going to be a that son
and this son right these boys
are gonna be your boys your daughter's
gonna be your daughter these kids are
gonna be y'all's kids and that's gonna
be that
everybody's gonna be treated equally and
loved and engaged
and all that stuff right don't get that
language even in your head
okay so when it comes to telling your
son
i can't recommend enough that you
you've got to get with a professional at
this point that's going to walk you
through and there's
all kinds of ways to do that in very
gentle ways
there's just some some gentle ways that
a good
counselor and you're talking two or
three sessions this isn't a monumental
thing
and if he hasn't has he gone to
counseling for a trauma with his mom
lost
um you know i probably should have got
it done but
no i i haven't yet and i've i planned on
doing it
this year because me and my my wife
talked about it at the end of last year
probably something i should have done dr
john but hey my life is kind of chaotic
at that point
hey um there's no judgment here man
we're gonna we're gonna take tomorrow as
a new day and we're gonna go from there
okay
and so here's what i want you to do i
want you to reach out to a
reputable um counselor who works with
kids in your area
let him know the situation that you
adopted this son from his birth with his
birth mom
and then she passed away a few years ago
he's 12
as he starts to hit puberty trauma is
the way i explain it is like taking a
bouncy ball and just humming it into
a kitchen everybody can throw that
bouncy ball and it's going to bounce in
a
million different directions but the
hormones the
the connection the desire to have deeper
relationship with friends
you know romantic relationships all that
stuff starts happening now
in a in a much more accelerated fashion
and so trauma is going to emerge in some
wonky ways
for him okay it's normal it's natural
you should expect it your new wife
should expect it
but you can start preempting some of
that now if you're not already seeing
i'd be surprised if you weren't already
seeing it but maybe you're not
and um get with a counselor let them
know that you want to start
talking through some of those things and
that you want some
guidance and some support as you all
begin to tell them hey
i'm not your biological dad but i'm
daddy i'm not your biological father
there's a better way to say that but i'm
your dad i chose
you of all the kids in the world i chose
you
i will always love you you're my oldest
son
we're about to have a new son and here's
an awesome way to um that
one of my professors dr marvel taught me
and it worked like a
champ man was when my wife got pregnant
with our
second she said start referring
to the second baby to the baby
in utero as their baby so you're gonna
start telling your son hey man when
you're
when your brother comes you're gonna
have a lot of responsibility
you and me we're gonna raise a good
young man here
we're gonna we're gonna really help him
be compassionate and empathetic and kind
we're gonna man me and you man your
brother your brother
and he's gonna take ownership and he's
gonna be excited and he's gonna have a
participation role and um own this big
brother stuff instead of seeing it as a
intrusion right someone who's taking
something from me right well i heard i
heard you talk about that a couple
episodes ago and that's the first thing
i did when we found out
yeah look at you man is your brother
and and yeah like that and i and i want
to say that
my wife wasn't one like i don't want her
to seem like she's
a bad guy mr nothing she she wasn't
going to say
you know this is your sign this is your
biological
she was just she works in social work
and she's just
trying i guess try to point me in the
right direction and she might not know
everything
oh sure man and hey no i appreciate you
standing up for your wife man you're a
good guy
uh and i'm not trying to bad mouth your
wife what i do want everyone to be
cognizant of
is everything becomes different when you
hold
um in a blended family like this
that kid that new kid that comes along
usually it's two or three or five in
your case
i don't know 12 or 13 years later right
that new kid
can have a a bonding effect can be
the shiny new toy leaving these new
teenagers who desperately desperately
need their parents attention feeling
like
they're outside the loop and it can be
really easy for
a new couple who gets together to want
to really super bond over this new baby
that we share together
and then the older kids can feel that
right so it's not drinking the hatred or
anything just something to be cognizant
of to think through
and you got a good wife man there are
some out there
not so much brother so i'm talking to
you as much as i'm talking to our
listeners out there
if you've adopted a kid your kids or
your kids if you've married
into a family and you are co-raising
those kids they are your kids they are
your
kids they're your kids not well that's
my biological kid that's my step kit
nope they're your kids they are worthy
of love they're worthy of being
connected to
you hug them love them
hold them accountable discipline them do
all of the things that you got to do
but all that back to your original
question get with a professional that's
going to walk you through that's going
to gently unveil this to your kid in a
way that he can hear it
that he can digest it he can ask the
questions and more importantly he's
probably not going to have a lot of
questions to ask up front
but he is gonna over time ask more and
more questions and you want to set up an
environment
that he leaves that exchange with you
and a counselor he leaves that exchange
knowing
man my dad jonathan is a safe guy for me
to talk to
he loves me he chose me he walked
alongside my mama
when she passed away he's asking me to
help
raise this new baby my little brother
all that you want him super tethered in
as he gets older he's gonna feel more
and more untethered
mom's gone who's my real dad you'll walk
through those kind of questions
as the years go on but right now yeah
he's 12 years old you want to begin to
have that conversation asap and do it
with a professional this is not
something you just plop down and be like
well hey i got something to tell you son
um you will set off a chain reaction
inside of him that
will rage like a like a california
forest fire okay it'll take
years to put out so man i appreciate
your heart
to all you parents out there who've got
a young kid that you say
that you've adopted and you think man
it's just gonna stay between us
um i'm his dad i don't even need to tell
him because i'm always gonna be there
for
man secrets destroy
families secrets to story destroy
families
man you can't kelly can't tell you how
many calls we get how many emails we're
getting about
so i'm 24 and i just did 23 and me and
uh
dot dot dot the gig's up on on
those kind of private things if you got
a kid out of wedlock
and you know that they are down the
street or in the neighborhood or across
the country
and they don't know about you they're
gonna find you they're gonna find you
you gotta have that conversation sooner
rather than later
it's much better coming from you on your
terms
and you getting with the old baby mama
or baby daddy
and figuring out how you're gonna do
that because it's not gonna stay secret
for long and the longer the deception
the longer the lies go on
the hotter and louder that forest fire
is great question jonathan thank you so
much for joining us